sword art online all right I'm sure none
of us want to see a new SEO video but
hey there's a new movie up and as I live
in Asia now I was able to see its foil
to release in the english-speaking
countries so for once we get to cover
something that no english-speaking
YouTube channel has been able to cover
you see a few laughs online ordinal
scale is a newest addition to the FAO
franchise and it's set to be released in
selected screenings next month in Europe
America and Australia so if you have any
ability to watch it or just want to know
if this movie is any different from what
this franchise has offered so far
then here's everything you need to know
in a nutshell with no spoilers
the film is set after the events of
season 2 I start off by introducing us
to yet love and you device the altmer
which is an augmented reality device is
basically the oculus rift powered by the
graphics engine known as life bar jaw
these graphics are terrible
after this technology has come in you
gain ordinal scale being the hot new MMO
developed exclusively for the Alma
starting the new genre ar MMORPGs a UVW
a y'see it has monster spawning in
real-life locations reminiscent of the
scenes we saw at oh c'mon go first
launch actually no it's a more sensible
approach one go ever see any stampede of
people shuffling over each other
whenever some sick exercise Dragonite so
of course for the whole new gaming
technology up yeseo gang already busy
playing it cuz what reason would they
have not to write Hey considering what
we went through the last few times is
happening don't you think we should be a
bit more careful in case of technology
goes wrong again I don't never happen it
happens yes something becomes arrived
when old Sao bosses start spawning about
the city and it's up to our crew to
figure out how the new characters yoona
an AI idol program developed
specifically for ordinal scale Asia the
second ranked player in the entire game
and dr. Shi Gamora the developer of the
augment are all connected to the strange
events surrounding ordinal scale the
movie follows the formula they got the
franchise going in the first place new
devices new games new villains using the
technology for their own goal here is o
becomes God exerted are etc literally do
anything new or groundbreaking but if
that takes the best fit people like the
franchise thought and yes there were
really bits that people enjoyed and
builds on that resulting in technically
the best thing the franchise has done to
date but that's already saying too much
as the ball is never that high the first
thing the movie
right gives a sense that there is
something at stake again see the problem
with arts like alpha and excalibur is
that there is nothing really a sake for
dying even if the characters could
really act like it and any sense of
urgency and thus our investment was lost
because you can play your death laws as
dramatically as you like but when we
know you're about to respawn in a few
minutes they'll just look like it over
to Matt the crybaby wasting your time
dying when you could have got on the
[ __ ] payload the stakes are back but
this time they are different and without
spoiling specifics it's more about the
relationship that kirito and asuna built
up together and the relationship that
every SI a player has built up with each
other that is ultimately at stake here
it's not the same cliche if you die in
the game you die in real life or if you
guys will like to get a chance to die in
the game when you die in real life or if
you die in real life you are also killed
in real life so the stakes are more
personal which actually sound refreshing
as there's more reminiscent of the
intimate character drama we thought
mothers Rosario combines with a
large-scale event of FA oh yes there is
actual drama to be found here
surprisingly and it does this by putting
more focus on the romance between kirito
and asuna
who individually get the most screen
time this is the true sequel to iron
crack moreso than alpha and GGO
Excalibur or mothers rosario ever were
and it directly plays on the consequence
and developments that happens during
that arc and it's also extends to the
antagonist because for the first time in
the entire series we actually have some
antagonists with genuine motivations
behind actions emerges Lee oh no people
JIT reasoning that we are so used to as
we learn more about who these extra
characters are and the true nature of
the technology it makes sense on a
personal level why the events that are
happening are happening and
unfortunately I cannot expand on this
father without going into spoilers not
only that but they also provide a
genuine logical obstacle for Kirito to
overcome yes but once Kirito doesn't
start off as being completely
overpowered and it's not for some
contrived reason or why skinned villains
are even more opie well they are
illogical spoils the yukkuri tone is as
a person and the nature of how this game
works but while it may just sound like
I'm singing praise for this movie make
no mistake it may be a step up from
what's come before but it is still far
from great at the end of the day this is
still sore from line and the movie still
shares the same faults that plagued the
series and made a lot of it so hated in
the first place there are the same are
called plot holes and shallow characters
and the series was known for Arsenal
this time don't get more screen time
than usual but aside from her
silico still as useless as ever slime is
still unfortunately the side character
punching bag you is still the vex
marketing machine our Gil is black xenon
is present but doesn't really do much
and city has mostly shafted with a big
climactic moment being a glorious shot
of a passing breath laying it out on the
huge theater screen wow that's great
credit as a gnarly puppy which I find a
shame because I've walked out of the
theater feeling like the movie drops a
lot of potentials which I know something
we've all heard before from FAO but
unlike in the series it's not what it
did such ruin but it's what it didn't do
all the elements were there for this to
be great like a franchise turning piece
of work
we have sincere character drama
antagonists with real motivations and a
genuine obstacle for Caruso to overcome
and the movie did nothing with it Kirito
bean character became his obstacles in
about twenty three of a second by merely
brooding harder the drama was resolved
as none of the characters were really
getting any developments or changing a
soul by opinion and the antagonist
lacked any kind of depths that could
have been given to them with the
motivations they had in favor of being
cliche bad guys up again because here's
how to beat someone up it still was
shallow and predictable what sword art
online ever was and any interesting
scenes were never built on or explored
at all an overall comes up that's just
rather bland all said and done also the
transparency of the series is still as
apparent as ever as well the fanservice
is certainly not as tasteless as it was
in the series if it's still definitely
there and on top of this I can just
imagine the boardroom meeting discussing
helps to make the movie even more wildly
appealing than it already is
alright people I know sword art online
is the most popular anime out right now
but how do we make it even more popular
well because I'm advancing maybe I've
got it
how about sword out online with idols
yeah having said that if there was one
reason I was glad to see this on the big
screen is that the movie definitely
delivered on the animation and action
system to Yuki Carter again delivers the
soundtrack that has consistently been
one of Si ghosts - and the actual
sequence was managed to build on the
best ones of series has to offer seeing
this on the big screen was an absolute
treat and the final climactic clash was
the final sequence to come out of Sao by
a long shot being the largest scale
battle that looks amazing while paying
tribute to the entire franchise thus far
and along with the major bombastic
action scenes
also features very well done idol team
sue in its climax you know give that's
your thing
[Music]
well this in mind ordinal scale feels
like your typical average Hollywood
action blockbuster and that is it in a
nutshell it's a process we've walked
into an anime summer blockbuster and for
that reason you can even enjoy the best
part of it without having seen SEO at
all it takes the tried and true formula
of the iron cried art but adds a little
more focus on character motivations and
relationships while delivering some of
the best action sequences of series has
offer giving us the sequel to that art
fans always wanted it is however still
plagued for the same problems and issues
that make the theory so hated by some in
the first place and it's still very much
fao shadow characters predictable plot
and all how good is sword art online
ordinal scale well if you're looking for
a definitive myself if this movie is
worth watching then ask yourself this
have you ever found enjoyment out of
sword art online if you hated the
original series and this will not change
your mind if you're a fan and you'll
probably think this is orgasmic but if
you found any kind of enjoyment from the
original series especially the fast
heart then you will find something to
enjoy here especially to get the chance
to see from theaters so yeah for me it
was enjoyable so hopefully now actually
watch this video you don't need a race
to sum up all my points in a single
character but as I know there will be
plenty of people who'll just skip to the
end looking for some kind of racing then
I guess it was like I know a C+ out of
100 with sugar on top and puppies hey
guys hope you enjoyed the video thank
you very much this month to Jericho tell
gay brown Vincent Mooney Tekken sorry
Lau Ken and everyone else a patron for
helping to support me for this month now
I know I said I wouldn't be doing anime
reviews again as I feel like in this day
and age are a lot less relevant than
they used to be but others will the
theater release I know everyone who
doesn't go out and stream the first few
episodes see if it's for them also that
would be a good number of you actually
wanted to know how did the anime film
one so as we get a lot of animate
readings here in Asia I may end up doing
more reviews of anime film screen here
in the future
also since reviewing anime films and
theater is new for me
if you're interested in hearing a
spoiler if ik discussion of the film let
me know as I may put up another quick
video if enough people want to see it
and you know don't mind being spoiled or
whatever Lamarr from that that's it for
me
I've been gear up and I'll see you all
next time